concerns in a henderson neighborhood
after a 13-year-old boy is hit and
killed by what police are calling an
out-of-control driver officers tell us
that rex patchett was walking on the
sidewalk yesterday right near paradise
hills drive and horizon ridge parkway
when it happened that's where mary jane
belly is joining us live and mary jane
you spoke to neighbors who say speeding
has always been a problem
yeah that's absolutely right brian now
the speed limit here on east paradise
hills drive is only 35 miles per hour
neighbors who live in the area tell me
they see and hear people speeding along
this road all the time they say it's
especially concerning with manion middle
school nearby and where 13 year old rex
patchett went to school
i don't know if we need more signs if we
need flashing lights cassandra gordon
lives in the paradise hills neighborhood
her son is just two years younger than
rex patchett he's 11 and my biggest
thought was that could have been him
down the street she says drivers often
speed at night from skyline drive into
the area neighborhoods our neighborhood
put in a flashing stop sign recently
so i don't know if something like that
would help more but people just need to
realize there's kids here on skyline
drive there is a road bump marie murray
says those who live in the area call it
the manion bump she says drivers
speeding over the bump are major concern
for crashes because i live in the area i
know to slow down and to be aware of the
bump
and yet i can see that if there are
other drivers and other people on the
road that are not familiar with the road
i think if they're not being careful
it's definitely a danger murray says her
heart goes out to the patchett family as
her son also goes to manion middle
school it's heartbreak
now i spoke to rex patchett's
grandfather who says as you can imagine
this is a tough time for them he says
rex was on his way home for dinner when
he was hit his grandfather describes him
as a fun and loving kid reporting live
out here on skyline and east paradise
hills drive mary jane bolliesa live
local now